[Music]
good morning John it's Wednesday April
19th that's my house
that's affiliated woodpecker where is he
that's nice what isn't nice is what I
woke up to find this morning in my front
yard my house is for sale how could that
happen
that that's not okay to my house then
ought to sell my house Jack Wade Jack
Wade is my landlord and also Jack Wade
works for Lambros real estate and sells
houses apparently sometimes he sells the
houses that he owns I like this house
this is a great house it has this cool
basement thing where I can do my videos
and work and put anime posters on the
walls and it's like three blocks from
five different friends five hundred and
fifteen thousand dollars cuz it's this
house and the house hello okay thank you
bye that was a mortgage broker that's
how I'm feeling about this five hundred
fifteen thousand dollars for this house
in the house behind it he's not selling
one house or the other he's selling both
at the same time which is pretty
annoying really because I don't want two
houses I don't really know that I want
one house but I figured I'd try and
figure out how much that would cost it
probably should have just asked dad
because now I'm getting calls from
mortgage brokers all the time they get
very excited they're very nice
once you apply for a loan as if life
isn't already complicated enough right
love it in Missoula there's not a lot of
work and the winter is coming to suck
like today and yesterday we're pretty
horrible so I guess the spring can suck
two plus two of our friends who are
maybe going to move back to town aren't
gonna move back to town and that really
sucks the community is great
the people are great it's a comfortable
size for me I can get my head around it
I know where everything is having a look
for new ways to live and moving all of
our stuff out of this house that would
be a huge pain in the ass so I don't
know most likely scenario somebody buys
the house and they're glad that there's
a renter in it so that they can keep
making money on the rent or very up in
the air about this place
we're very up in the air about the
future of our lives I mean where you
live is extremely important and I'm
actually really starting to like having
some roots here you know being connected
with a place understanding the community
knowing who to ask about when to plant
garlic no one the guy that runs the
bookstore and talking to him about you
and how great your book is and how much
he liked it and how we've always has it
featured because it's kind of like a
local author because his brother lives
here that's the kind of place I like I
can go down to that bookstore and I can
tell you where people live by pointing
at books in the local section one of
them lives in my backyard her house is
for sale too looks like a pretty
interesting book it's called the god of
animals and it's about a twelve year old
girl so it's kind of young adult but I
think it's being marketed as adult
fiction I like it so far but I'm going
through the first couple chapters what
do we do what should we do my impulse is
just a it would help if more people had
that impulse because I'm tired of
watching friends leave this town well
now you know what's going on with me so
I guess I'll see you tomorrow
quick unrelated thing I wouldn't mind
some comments or suggestions about this
Eco Georg video podcast intro
[Music]